hey everybody its Jessie and today we're
gonna just continue with what we've been
doing yesterday I did a little bit more
so after the stream yesterday I pretty
much just was done with work hung out
with my family this morning I had a
meeting and so I did actually come in to
the office for the meeting and I stopped
over after the meeting in the IT
department and asked him about github
being blocked and they said it was okay
they could unblock it so I now have
access to github at work which means I
can stream from work and the quality can
go back to 1080p for the videos so I'm
excited about that I think it'll be a
much better experience for you all to
watch so also feeling good today cuz I
remember to eat so if you've watched my
strings before I often forget to eat and
then I'm like my stomach grumbling on
the stream so today I ate so I should
have more energy and hopefully my brain
will work better
let me I'm going to check how many
people we have see if we have a good
number to start okay yeah a decent
number number of people watching so I
didn't I didn't schedule the stream
until pretty recently so I didn't really
get a chance to put it out there on
Twitter and everything for the link so
I'm thinking maybe some people didn't
know the stream was gonna happen or was
the topic was so you may pick up some
people as time goes on I think I
actually forgot to check the box that
promoted the event beforehand so it's
probably just now
having notifications on everybody's apps
so sorry about the light I was just
checking some to make sure I didn't
forget any any other options okay
now the viewers are picking up a bit hey
everyone I'm just checking out the live
chat
oh cool Ben says it's first time
checking out the this live awesome glad
to have you here live some people said
it made made them want to eat I was
talking about food
Lance maker asked one will react classes
be available on free code camp I don't
know I don't know the answer you can
test out the the new version of free
code camp the beta version if you want
to I I think you'll lose your progress
and the other one I I don't know for
sure I haven't I haven't tested out the
new version myself so sorry I can't give
you a better answer but I don't know
that there's an a date set for the every
time I hear an answer it's usually like
soon but not an actual date
oh cool Sophie says this is her first
time as well for live thing thanks for
watching thanks for joining live it's
really awesome I think to be here live
because you get to ask questions not
just to me but everybody in a live chat
is really knowledgeable and you can
usually get some some really good
answers to questions that you may have
so I'm gonna get started just really
quick I'm gonna explain what we're
trying to do in case you weren't able to
watch yesterday's episode what we're
trying to do
let me bring over the actual site for
you so what I'm trying to do is to take
this section of the site this just has
resources so we want to be able to sort
these resources by category which we're
going to add a drop-down for category at
some point to want to be able to I'm
sorry filter them by category filter
them based on whether the resource is
free or is it it's paid also based on
what type of resource it is and then be
able to search within them we also want
to be able to sort them alphabetically
and also by by date added so if you can
think of another way to sort them that
would be useful let me know we don't
have any type of rating system on here
right now and that's not it was
mentioned but it's definitely not gonna
make it in this round of updates but for
now you know those are the main things
that they need to get added for today's
show I need to keep this show today to
an hour because my wife is gonna go get
her hair done so I have to go home and
watch the kids
so I have an alarm set to stop me in an
in an hour so hopefully we can get just
as much done as we can in an hour so let
me go to the code I'll show you this the
little bit that I've added which is
really not much at all so basically all
I've done is
I've added another filter so this is the
filter that we did yesterday let me make
this a little bigger for you all so this
is the filter that I added yesterday
and this one was just kind of a test
we're gonna modify this a bit because
that's some good feedback in the live
chat saying that we should add another
option besides just the toggle if you
wanted to see things that are free and
paid at the same time so we're going to
do that but then I added this other
filter and this is going to be our
category filter I did do some work on
the PHP plugin that we had made to
handle our all our custom post types
so I created I use this function to
create a new taxonomy a custom taxonomy
so it's called resource category and
this resource category taxonomy gets
applied to resource the custom post type
of resource in our WordPress content
management system so now there'll be
this category if you've ever worked with
WordPress you know that I guess I could
just bring it over I have it on the
other screen so on WordPress I know this
is small make it a little bigger so
normally like on a blog post you would
have a little box over here that just
said categories and you can check the
categories well now we have resource
categories and the way it's nice to do
it like this instead of using the the
plug-in that I'd use for these custom
fields which is advanced advanced custom
fields plug-in I like to do it this way
for categories and tags because this
takes advantage of all the native
category functionality that comes with
WordPress so these resource categories
will now act like just like the
categories for WordPress so I think this
is just a little bit nicer and more
familiar to users I I do like the custom
advanced custom fields for a lot of
other things and it works really well
but in this case it's just so easy to
do the PHP I mean look at this it's
basically you know I didn't write all
this out this is copy and pasting and
then just changing the name you're
literally going in here and just using
you know the multiple cursors to go in
and change the name of everything okay
so it took you know probably a minute or
less to update this plugin there's so
that's about that's about it so I did
start to make this function that's gonna
we're gonna filter by so here it is I
started the stream right in the middle
of making it so basically my thought
process here in this function is that
it's going to take in whatever the post
happens to be right off the bat if the
category equals all it's just gonna
return true because it doesn't really
matter what you know every post is in
the category all but if it's a so if a
user has selected something else other
than show all they've selected a
category then it's going to take into
account you know is what it is that
category and it's going to try to
compare so here's where I'm at I'll show
you the data just give you an idea of
why I'm doing it like this so in
WordPress the WordPress API is gonna
give us this data this is actually a
little bit more than I'm gonna get I'm
gonna cut this down because there's a
lot of necessary data but the data that
we really want to know about is this
right here each category each resource
category has its own ID it's gonna give
us the ID not normally this is a pain
but I'm already going to be making an
API call to get the categories including
their IDs for our drop-down so I'm
already gonna have access to that data
so it won't be a big deal to match up by
ID number instead of by category name
which would make more sense and be
easier to remember I can get the
category name here if I wanted to but I
don't think it's going to be necessary
rather not pull all of this and if I
don't have to it doesn't make a deal big
deal if you're only pulling in a few
posts but if if the website grows and
later on there are a lot of there's a
lot of data to pull in then it'd be
better to just trim it down so I need to
match up categories but the category
returns an array so resource category as
an array so potentially a resource could
belong to multiple categories so I need
to make sure that I trip check each
element in this array each number to see
if it matches up so that's why I have
this well I'm going to go through this
I've done a map right now and this is
where I stopped so I'm gonna have to
look at this for a second just to
remember what my thought process was
because before I do that I should check
the live chat just to make sure see if
anybody who's maybe new has some
questions let's see
we have looks like no questions but do
that if someone's near eyes says it's
not blurry anymore thank you yeah deaf
no I'm in the office so when I stream
from home the quality is not great but
now I have great internet connection and
so it should be a good quality as long
as your connection is good quality you
should be able to stream this in 1080p
and it looks like from the the analytics
that there are there equated I would say
most people were doing seven getting
720p right now but the second highest
amount of people are getting 1080p
almost tied there was 720 so I don't
know if you I don't think I've ever
showed you the analytics this just
doesn't have anything to do with the
topic today but I'm thought it'd be cool
to show so this is what I see what I'm
looking at when I talk about the
analytics so if you've never streamed
before you might not see this but this
gives me how many viewers we have lots
of lots of things I usually don't even
look at this stuff
too often when I'm trying to do this but
there's the live chat I can't actually
view it in public but that would get
crazy because I would hear myself on the
delay and so I don't do that but this at
least lets me know how many viewers we
have and you know gives me a little
estimation about the stream quality so
anyway just thought I'd share that since
I'm always looking at it but I just not
sure if you all knew what it would it
look like
okay oh I did do it one question so one
question appeared Ben asks anyone ever
an issue with dynamically rendering
something like an accordion panel and
have the title appear on set State but
no functionality until page reload also
he said sorry for the interruption see I
have had I'm trying to understand think
about what's going on here I have had
issues with trying to like initialize
things and it not working until I
actually did so when I like when I
navigated through just client-side
rendering with no page refresh things
wouldn't work but then if I did a like a
refresh and actual refresh in the
browser they would work so I have that
things like that happen but I'm not
exactly sure that that's what you're
asking so maybe someone else in the live
chat understands this a little better
and could give a good answer
I think I'm probably missing let me know
Ben and if you need to you can direct
message me or something and or give me
like an example I'd be happy to check
out the code and test it see if I could
help
all right so I'm gonna I'm gonna start
going into some of the code now okay Ben
said I do understand the problem yeah so
I'm assuming then that the the accordion
panel has to be like initialized they s
be initialized somehow with JavaScript I
have this issue if I try to use like
something with jQuery that needs to be
you would normally put in a document
already function I've had success with
putting that same initialization code
into the let me show you an example
since I I'm here I think I have it okay
so inside component did mount like I'm
initializing in this case the tabs so
these tabs otherwise these tabs wouldn't
usually they would work on first page
like if i refresh the page but they
wouldn't work otherwise if I went
client-side so I'm not sure if that
helps if that's possible and then the
way I basically this just calls a
function the this calls a function that
initiates it in my JavaScript file so
within here this isn't in a document dot
ready function all right this is just
out there I will say there's a better
way to do this and for some of the stuff
that I coded later on in this site I did
use a more like react style way of doing
things but this does work and it's
helpful especially if you already have
some stuff coded you don't really have
time to convert it all over this worked
for me Veon it tabs right here it's just
I'm using a materialized framework so
there's not a lot of code in here it's
just the initialization so anyway I hope
that that helps somewhat
and like I said if you need like some
more help my Twitter link to my Twitter
is in the show description so I just you
know send me a message on there and I'd
be happy to help more okay so let's
finish this this filter here so as I
said the thought is I need to I need to
look through all of the in this case we
don't have any posts that have belong to
multiple categories but down the road we
probably will so I need to make sure
that I go through each category that's
listed for the post and see if it
matches now I'm sure there's try a
better way to do this but the first
thing that popped into my head was well
what if I just have a variable that's
set to 0 and if any of these are true
right so if the category equals what's
in this state this an auto auto
completed another this inertia this
state category so if the category equals
this state category then it'll just add
1 to that variable and then if that
variable is greater than 1 then it will
return true or I'm sorry greater than 0
it will return true ok and then that way
we should know I mean if you have a if
there's a better way and I'm just
missing some simple way to do this let
me know because this seems like a bit
much to just get this result so I'm
probably just like blanking out on a
simple answer here
oh I'll start working on this and then
I'm sure there's a little delay in the
video so I'll be working on this but if
someone has a good idea and wants to put
in the live chat I'm definitely open to
your ideas on how to do that so I guess
I can just do
so if that's the case then we want to do
actually
I don't know what I was thinking okay I
don't have to do this all right let's
try this let me know if this will work
so I don't have to do it like that
I don't need this either now's a great
time for the usual disclaimer this is
your first time watching this I'm not an
expert this is just a show that lets you
see my usual work I am employed
full-time as a front-end developer at a
university but this is not really a
tutorial this is just a glimpse into my
normal day and this is very much a
collaborative effort between all of you
watching and in the live chat and and me
and I hope that I helped some some of
you to learn how to do some things but
really I end up learning a lot from you
all as well so if you're wondering why
I'm I just deleted what I what I wrote
and I know I have a better idea it's
because this is not pre-recorded it's
not rehearsed at all you know this is
just my normal workflow so that said
here's my new idea my new idea is I can
just return can't type today I just
returned true
if if that's the case so if if then I
return true otherwise I need to return
false somewhere right so
now I can't return false yet maybe I did
need to do it the other way and I just
kind of outfought myself here all right
what I'm thinking I need is basically
this is fine but what I need to do is if
it goes through each of the categories
and this is never true when it reaches
the end then I need to return false so
I guess if I put it out here that would
work yeah I think it would work out here
because this will get evaluated first
then this and it'll loop through
everything so it'll never get down here
if either one of these are true it'll
never get to this point and in case
there's people who are new to JavaScript
normally the way it works is once you
return something then anything below the
return it just doesn't happen you just
exit the function so that's what I'm
counting on here to kind of simplify
things so I think that should work now I
haven't built out any of the UI to to
test this yet but we can hard code some
of the things into state just to give it
a test so for now which should happen
since we have the state by default is
four categories all it should show us
all the posts
so let me well assuming I didn't make
any errors here unexpected token don't
you see
alright so do I have a category I
probably just something with the syntax
let me check it out I mean compare that
so I think I was doing something similar
down here and it worked oh you know what
I think
no I'm not sure I'm sure
okay Pedro asks why are you using map to
loop over that array I guess I didn't
need to use maps to loop over the array
I was just using that so much elsewhere
I thought I would use it is there some
benefit to using just a regular loop in
this case okay sage you says I forgot
some curly brackets so let's see where
did I forget oh okay
assume you're saying right here after at
the curly brackets and I need sure I'm
thinking okay she's trying to figure out
where I needed to copy it from see that
fixes it no didn't know I probably
copied this wrong it did something wrong
sorry I wasn't I was looking at
something on my other screen sorry for
the period of silence there okay what
Benjamin says in the live chat I'm
missing some parentheses after map
category
okay so I should put category in
parentheses yes
okay
let's see that
now I probably
it's odd seems like everything's buzzing
this is real programming right here
trying to figure out where you misplaced
a bracket or parentheses
okay Sergio all right now Benjamin
saying or no
Sergio says one line lower after bracket
okay let's see
so I should put this one line lower then
I'm assuming this is if Hey all right
well that's a different error so I'm
happy with that that's progress
so filter by category is not defined
much lines
that's odd obviously it was defined
hmm
I
it did i just restarted the dev server
for some reason and if you've been
watching for a while some previous shows
something's weird with my dev server and
it's odd because it doesn't have like if
i pull down this this repo on other
machines i don't have the problem but on
this machine my dev server just will
will just hang and it'll just act
it'll just load you know it looked like
it's loading for a long time and nothing
happens why is
I'm just reading through making sure
didn't misspell something down here
that looks like it's fine everything's
spelled right hey Sebastian just came in
the live chat how's it going I'm glad
you could join in
okay there was actually some discussion
in the live chat about my use of map so
I just want to fill you oh and in case
you're watching later on I can't see the
chat so Pedro had asked me why I was
using map to loop over that array and
let's see what bill said map is more
efficient than four or four each if I
remember correctly Pedro says says no
map is used when you want to return an
array based on the previous one
all right so is the consensus then that
I should totally change this and not use
map or is it cool to just use map I also
have some do some things here it says
Sergio says you don't have if you only
have one parameter to the function to an
arrow function you don't need to put it
in brackets that's what I thought so so
I did I didn't have them at first and
then I threw them in there so let's
let's just remove some of this and try
to simplify it and then maybe it'll be
easier for me to see what is going on
and why I why I keep getting an error
okay so this should be simple flashed I
should be able to do this with the arrow
now I have so that's in the right place
that's in the right place this closes
that exclusion to that all right I'm
pretty sure that's what I had before so
let's see if I get the same error okay
yeah I'm getting I'm getting an error
here so obviously I'm doing something
wrong then in the way that I'm doing
this maybe I ought to just do a normal
loop
Oh Sebastian Sebastian said he missed
yesterday because I was at the pool
ocelots I was uh I was in the pool
myself a few days ago I got actually and
all my kids are in the pool with me and
I they wanted me to keep like throwing
them and see like how high in the air
can I throw them and then they'd fall
splash in the water and I'll tell you
what I was really sore after throwing
them for for a long time so it was a
great workout if you're looking for some
good you know alternative workouts go
throw some kids around in a pool
hopefully they'll be your own kids
though cuz no it's not your parents
would like it if you described their
kids randomly okay so Pedro is actually
written some code and posted it in the
live chat to try so Thank You Pedro I'm
gonna I'm gonna copy and paste what
Pedro has put in here and see how that
does I really appreciate that Pedro all
right so let's paste this in let me see
okay it's the whole function so put this
whole thing in here
actually insert you I see yours now - so
man too bad they don't have like you
can't put code in to the live chat and
have it be formatted so let me make this
a little bit formatted OOP filter by
category
I guess I don't know let's see if it
works first and then I'll format it no
sense in formatting it if it's not gonna
work I'll shoot now I'm getting this
this arrogant filter by categories not
defined
actually I don't I don't even need to
format this since we're using prettier
as soon as we commit this then it'll do
all the work for us so it's a waste of
time right now all right so I suppose at
some point what we put in did work
because we're getting the same error now
with with this with what Pedro gave
which I'm assuming also will work so
okay I'm Barrett oh thanks for bringing
that up again I'm Barrett I said
remember that there may be non print
characters when you copy and paste so
let me
okay it doesn't matter this is space
there yeah the last time this happened
on a copy things I just had to go
through like this although usually when
that happens the error message tells me
at least where this space is this error
message is not it looks good what do you
usually happen is there's like some
space that's not visible to me but as I
go through with the arrow key I'll hit
the arrow key twice and the cursor won't
move it won't move twice it'll stay in
the same spot once and then I know
there's some invisible tiny space there
so
all right so now we're getting some I'm
getting some feedback in the live chat
that's it oh man good good job Pedro all
right let me let me share why I just
said that Pedro said you have to use
this dot filter by categories how many
times this happens to me I don't know if
I want to say frequently but maybe like
once every week or so at least I forget
to use this when I need to use this so I
don't know does that happened to anyone
else I can't just put filter by category
there I got to put this all right let's
try it now
all right notice it's refreshed there
you go
well that's still not what I wanted what
is going on oh I just said it zoom then
okay all right so
I don't think this is all of them so
we're so something's not something's not
working
hmmm that was
that was odd because that gave us all
the posts but if you see like this
should have gone through the same like
when this state changed it should have
rerender gone through the same filter
process so it just didn't work right off
the bat which is which is probably just
due to my my dev server freezing again
okay so I'll just restart that quickly
but basically that worked so Pedro thank
you and sorry everyone for overlooking
that really really basic thing that I
needed to do and taking up a lot more
time than I needed to with that so
Sampson says I'm loved I am loving this
awesome thanks Sampson I'm glad you're
enjoying it so alright so we have our
category filter that's working now now
what I want to do is change right now
the only category that I added in that I
have the I thought I pulled over the
actual JSON here we go so let me pull
this over to show you what I added so
the only category I have right now is
would just be two so I should be able to
put two in there in in the state of I
said I hope it doesn't mess it up that I
basically put in I think I'm gonna
change this so that I'm not going back
and forth between strings and numbers so
what I'm gonna do is category is going
to be zero and so now down here instead
of saying category this state category
equals all I'm just gonna say equals
zero and then that way we can just keep
the same type I know
it probably would've worked
regardless where's our
okay
actually so we're still getting the same
thing here where we're not we're not
actually getting everything being
returned let me do refresh again
yeah that's odd so something's wrong
then
all right let's go through
I had some questions about what I'm
working with so yeah this is it looks
kind of like HTML but it's actually
called JSX so it it's like HTML makes
with JavaScript basically and that's
what it's react react is is a JavaScript
library framework that lets you do stuff
like this in intermix HTML and
JavaScript it does a lot of things but
like just to really simplify it a lot
you can mix HTML and JavaScript and it
sounds like it's not a good idea at
first but it actually ends up being
really nice okay so at this point this
isn't causing an error anymore but it is
actually filtering out some things that
we want so let me make sure I had price
paid no it's not that's my fault I uh I
had set the price paid to be the default
let's change the default to what was it
is it free trying to think what the
value is
I think free is the value for that so I
had forgotten that we were already
filtering so this is actually working
and since I changed it we'll see now it
is actually showing me so I was mistaken
that is working so because we never
changed that this filter for price to
show all by default so we'll have to do
that and I don't know if we'll have time
for that or not because I do want to
answer your question so I'll probably
stop the actual coding a few minutes
early so that I can answer your
questions so you may not get to that but
I do want to test this so we should be
able to put in two and we should only
see one post if I put in two because
that's the only cat
Gouri that I've created and I've only
applied it to one post which cannot be
properly sum of undefined let's see I
may need to put in a check here because
okay yeah so what's happening is it's
saying it's undefined because some of
the data it's go to the next one it's
giving an empty array so let's just do
I guess I could say if if Resource
Academy I'm gonna have to do like some
nested statements here yeah it's not
gonna be the most beautiful thing if
it's what I want to do is to say if the
post resource category oops I don't know
why I named it with a hyphenated thing
and then now I have to use these
brackets instead that was a mistake but
I wasn't thinking when I was doing the
PHP for this
okay so else the first resource category
equals is not equal to undefined right
yeah if it's not equal to undefined then
I want to do this stuff
No
and then
okay let me check my my brackets up that
bracket matches this one matches okay
that should work and just to explain
what I was doing here I know a lot of
you are like more advanced and you don't
need explanation but if someone is not
quite as familiar with JavaScript or any
other stuff I like to give a little
explanation I don't want to leave anyone
behind if if it can be prevented so what
we needed to do was put in a check to
see if it was undefined so that we don't
get that error so if it's undefined if
the resource category is undefined that
means we have an empty array so no
category has been assigned if it hasn't
been assigned to any category it's
obviously not going to match so we don't
even have to check to see if it matches
we can just return false immediately so
all right cool so we haven't gotten the
error oops
but we didn't get we didn't get the post
that we wanted either
and see what happened
let me see it's possible - that's a paid
resource that has that category so
before I I'm still not seeing it
you know why singing forever
okay
all right well this is reloading I'm
gonna check the live chat and we'll
probably hopefully I can get this to
work and not end with it not working but
I'm gonna stop the coding in a few
minutes regardless and shoot yeah all
right so it's not giving us so uh so
this is the data that is being pulled in
wait a second
I know why it's not working I was trying
to get this this part of things finished
before I started the stream and I didn't
get it done and I forgot I didn't get it
done so I need to what I'm doing when I
make the API call is I'm filled I'm
selling it exactly the fields that I
want and I did not put in there the
resource field so it wasn't pulling it
in so it basically appeared like there
every time I used that it was undefined
let's see alright great so see it it is
working so this is the post that I put
it on so awesome so the filter works so
basically the next step would be make a
drop-down that actually pulls in and
we'd have to make an API call the API
how could you be made separately and it
doesn't necessarily have to be
server-side rendered that wouldn't be a
big deal so it could be made client-side
but in any case we make an API call that
would grab all the categories and then
we would get the value of that so
basically every time the value of that
element changed then we would call a
function that changed the state so
just doing this set state that would
change the state of category to the
number that corresponds to the name of
that category that would trigger a
rerender and then everything would get
filtered through and then our category
filter would work so if that doesn't
make sense to anybody let me know in the
live set I'll try to explain it because
maybe maybe my thought process is wrong
but at this point we've got about seven
minutes until I want to end the stream
so I can get home one time so I'll take
any questions let me someone just asked
about es lint or something so that just
reminded me that this will turn prettier
when I commit because we're using
prettier so I'm gonna do a commit
I just don't on my other screen I've
gone through the process of doing get
commits often so if you're not familiar
with git we have a lot of good videos on
this channel the free code camp channel
not for me but we have some good videos
on how to use git and on some of my
previous streams I've I've explained it
a little bit but it's nothing like a
comprehensive tutorial so if you need to
know some more practice with that I
recommend you know some of the other
videos and there's a lot of other good
resources out there as well alright so
that cleaned it up and now I'm gonna go
through the live chat and just to make
sure I didn't miss anyone's question
from earlier if you have any questions
right now please put them in the chat if
you were just here for the code part of
it and you can't stick around for for
the Q&A part of the show then thanks for
watching and I'll probably be back
tomorrow it might be a little later I
might have to push it back to 2:30
Eastern Time 2:30 p.m. Eastern Time
because I'll be doing another phone
interview for a web developer position
that we'll be hiring here hopefully soon
so I'll let everyone know on Twitter and
then you'll you'll get the the update
through YouTube if you're subscribed to
the channel so otherwise if you're gonna
stick around please put your question in
the live chat now I'll try to get to all
the questions if I run out of time then
you can direct message me the question
or put it on Twitter or you can put it
in the comments for this video alright
so I'm starting up at the top I'm just
going to scroll down and try to take the
questions as I get to them I'm not gonna
read everything just to save time but
anything that's like directly a question
for me that I can help with I will
answer
Oh looks like someone put something in
the comments but it's in a different
alphabet than I'm used to reading so I'm
sorry I won't be able to answer that
right now if I had more time I'd
probably try to use Google Translate but
I'm not gonna do it now if you're still
here if you're this was early on if
you're still watching if you direct
message it to me or put it in the
comments then I will take the time to
use Google Translate and I'll answer you
back I'll translate it back into your
language and try to answer you back that
way and Google Translate is pretty good
now so we should be able to understand
each other let's see okay someone asked
about my editor which Rowland answered
thanks Ron it is Adam oh so custom
crawler production says hello been
trying to learn to write code on your
website and it's a lot of fun so thanks
for that
awesome I'm glad that that you're
learning let me know if you have
questions it's not I mean it's not my
personal website free code camp so I
just you know do some some videos for
them so I can't take any credit at all
the website but I myself going through a
lot of the stuff on the site and a lot
of the problems to learn more so I'm
glad that you're finding it helpful
naveen says guys have a look at vs code
so it's Visual Studio code ya Visual
Studio code is really nice I used it a
bit in some of my early streams for a
different project that I was working on
and I'll probably use it when I go back
to that project so I do use that as well
as Adam
as when asked is there any good
responsive UI framework for react so I
have never used it but I think there is
a bootstrap react framework and I assume
it's responsive because bootstrap is
responsive and I know bootstrap is
pretty reliable in general so I like
that this is just I'm assuming that the
react version of it works for I use
materialize for my framework but not the
react version I'm just trying to
basically make it work in react
I'd love to switch over to something
that's like entirely you know based in
the the react style of doing things and
I know there are some material design
react frameworks that are responsive I
just haven't had the time to really test
them out and see which one I like so I
can't give you a great answer to that
just some ideas hopefully I find a good
one for a future project
okay still just going through it trying
to find a question
oh and there's there's my alarm so I'm
almost through all the chat so I'll go
just a few more minutes to find to
answer the rest of the questions oh no
at some point about a half hour ago
sealion lost sound so I guess not much I
can do about it now I wish I would have
seen would have seen that did it did
anyone else lose some I'm assuming that
it was no one else lost sound because
I'm not saying any other messages about
that but sorry see Lynam hopefully the
sound came back in for you and assuming
the sound is okay on the recording you
can catch the the recording later on and
appear with the rest of the video
Atta s is coding hard I would say coding
yeah I mean I guess it's hard it's hard
I don't want to say it it's easy cuz I
think it's misleading to say it's easy
like I've been doing this for years so
there are some things to me that seem
easy now that at first were really
really hard and there are things like
obviously anybody that's watched this
show knows there are things for me that
are still really hard things don't
always go the way you want them there
are bugs
so yeah coding can be hard but once you
get experience a lot of it isn't hard
anymore and a lot of it is actually
really fun so at first when you first
start out it a lot of it can be really
hard because you're just not familiar
with it
but so if you're starting to learn how
to code and things seem hard for you
don't feel like you're not cut out for
this it's hard it's a it's hard for
everybody I know a lot of people say
coding is easy and saying anybody could
do it
I don't think that's true I think people
just probably forget how hard it was
when they first started and it's it's
not easy it takes a lot of hard work I
do think pretty much anybody could do it
if they put the work into it if they
were dedicated and really wanted to do
it
but that doesn't mean it's easy so
hopefully that answered your question
if anyone else has anything to add to
that in the live chat you please do
XANA XANA
i don't know how to pronounce that but
i'm just going to say XANA I'm not I'm
not sure if that's like a culmination of
words or it's supposed to be all
together as one name I don't know but
Suzanna says so sorry just got here late
yeah no problem about that with love
some live coding on beginning react I
need to catch on it quick then react
native lots to learn currently on code
Academy or code Academy 82% of the
beginning course there can we discuss
projects and tasks we have like can I
come up with questions when I get stuck
and if I catch you live yeah so base I
think your ass you're asking a couple of
things but right now I would love to do
some videos that are more like beginner
based tutorials but and I've been saying
this for a long time and I apologize
that I haven't come out with very many
videos or you know tutorial videos at
all I just I've been really busy
I've started a react course that I'm
doing also in my my free time so I've
just been busier than I thought I would
be
and this website it's taken me longer
than it was supposed to take so I don't
have those videos yet and I can't give
you for short time on when I would be
able to get some beginning videos I did
do the course on code Academy as well so
that's a good start
there's a course that Udacity is
offering right now it is a paid course
though if the money is not a problem for
you so far I've been impressed with the
course if you just want free resources
though then I'm trying to think what I
used for reacts I mean reiax
documentation is that is really good I
would encourage you to try using next
js' because it does a lot of things for
you that sometimes can be intimidating
when you're starting out like you know
just
sets up everything so you can just start
to code so and yeah if you have projects
and stuff and you want to ask a question
feel free I always try to do QA at the
end of my videos or you know you can
message me on Twitter or something and
I'll I'll try to help you as much as I
can
Brian asks how do you get square tabs
and Adam I'm not sure you mean up at the
top these square tubs
I don't really know maybe it's just a
theme I'm using I don't know how there's
how they would look otherwise do they
look different than other themes I'm
using the SETI theme so s SETI so maybe
that's why okay Tim asked wait what part
is PHP did I hear um you know you did
not hear wrong there was some PHP so
what I did in PHP is the content
management system for this react site is
actually WordPress WordPress is built
with PHP so I needed to make a custom
plugin for all the different custom post
types that I wanted and for custom
taxonomies so this is that plug-in so
this is all PHP that's on the screen now
and to see it's just just a simple
plug-in that I had I have made and it
looks like it's a lot but really all
this is just the same thing kind of
copied and pasted for each post type so
it's really not that difficult and then
I just upload this you know into
WordPress like you would a normal
WordPress plug-in and that's the extent
of the PHP that I really need to do for
this just really simple I'm not a PHP
developer at all I just know enough to
do some things in WordPress and do like
basic like form stuff with PHP like I
can build a file uploader
in PHP and you know really basic things
like that which comes in handy
especially if you're working on a site
that's on shared hosting a lot of times
shared hosting will not let you install
a node so you can't do it in JavaScript
but they will have PHP available so if
you can write some basic things in PHP
it does come in handy
Oh Pedro says next time I hope to be at
the beginning of streaming and help if I
can
awesome pedra I really appreciate that I
hope to see you back in some future
streams and thanks for all your help in
this stream to you you were a really big
help
you were actually you were the key to
the solving the the errors that was I
was getting sir do you ask anyone know
any other streams on coding I tell you
truth I don't watch a lot of coding
streams but I'm pretty sure Google
developers has some live coding
sometimes I can't remember what it's
called supercharged or something like
that I can't remember what the series on
their channel is called but let's check
out like the Google coders channel on
YouTube and there's somebody else I
think his name was Andy M so a and dy e
m would be like his last name he does
some live coding stuff that I've seen
but he doesn't I've seen his stuff he
doesn't narrate as he's going he just
has music playing in the background so a
little bit different style but still
live live coding I don't know of any
other ones though if anyone has any you
know put it in the chat now or you know
put it in the comments below the video
and if it's legit I know normally if you
put links into a comments on YouTube you
will it'll get marked as spam but I
check out all the comments even the ones
that get thrown in spam and if I see
that it's a legitimate comment I'll
prove it and it'll get on there anyway
so don't don't worry about that
oops and Philip said he was having
trouble hearing me as well so I'm really
sorry about that
hopefully that was just two people at
trouble I hope it's not happening I mean
sometimes I move around and I like put
my face closer to one screen or another
to try to look at the code so I'm not
exactly facing the microphone so it
might just be me moving around that's
causing the issues being able to hear me
so I'll try to remember to speak more
into the microphone Shannon says if you
need a nice workout you need a big
garden lots of work all day actually I
have a garden I wouldn't call it a big
garden maybe a medium-sized garden I
don't really know but I haven't been
doing any work at it hardly at all
because I've been so busy my wife's been
doing all the work some years I do a ton
of work in the garden but this years
just hasn't been time but I do agree
gardening is can be hard work especially
keeping up with all the weeds Phillip
says do you ever have access to multiple
taxonomy x' through the wordpress API
how do you handle those I'm actually
trying to find a way to handle those
properly right now so I don't have a
great answer for you but I can tell you
my ideas so obviously you can make lots
of API calls to each of those taxonomy
x' and grab the data and then do
whatever you need to what I'm trying to
find is a way to get all those different
all that different data in one API call
I found a plug-in that lets you get some
but unfortunately you can't use like
different parameters for each type so
you basically just have to get all of
everything which is okay unless you have
more than you know the post limit which
is a hundred and so I haven't found a
solution that I really like yet but
maybe I'll do a video when I finally do
find a good
Ellucian and let you know see lioness
are these live sessions done on a set
schedule yes pretty much I try to stream
every day well Monday through Friday at
2 p.m. Eastern Time I don't always get
to do it at 2:00 so occasionally I need
to adjust the time or sometimes I need
to cancel all together depending on
what's going on but I'll try to be as
consistent as I can be and I'll let you
know through Twitter so if you follow me
on Twitter then every day I I'll tweet
what time the stream is going to be and
if I'm not going to do a stream I'll let
you know also if you're a subscriber to
the free code camp channel you should
get a notification on your phone or
through the browser about when streams
are happening so basically Monday
through Friday 2:00 p.m. Eastern but
occasionally a different different time
ally says Thank You Jessi are you
welcome thanks for watching
nits dog-ass said sorry if this sounds
stupid this is odd
don't worry about don't I don't want
anyone to ever worry about a question
sounding stupid like I fully expect
there to be people of all levels and
experience levels so if you're you know
starting out or you're just maybe a
really experienced you're just not
familiar with what I'm doing like with
react or anything like that then your
your question might be one that's easy
to some people and not easy to others so
don't worry about that but the question
is this is a wordpress site are you
using a custom theme or plugins to do
this so it's kind of a wordpress site
the all the content is in WordPress but
I'm using the WordPress API to grab that
content and use it in a separate react
site so the WordPress and the react site
exists on two different servers two
different droplets on digitalocean so I
don't really need a theme for WordPress
because no one will ever at view it like
directly through WordPress but I do have
some WordPress plugins that make it
easier for me to get the data and add in
the different post types and fields that
I need
Andre says coding isn't easy takes a lot
of dedication and daily training and
find your pace and just do it every day
okay also I think that was probably in
response to an earlier question about
coding being hard and that's a great
great response
Andre also says if you want to work in
the industry study a bit about agile and
how software projects work with the
agile methods and apply that agile idea
to your learning that's a great idea
Andre so yeah if you're not familiar
with agile check it out I did take a
course on agile it was through
Pluralsight which sometimes you can find
deals where you can get Pluralsight for
free for a couple of months
so try to find one of those deals and
maybe you could take the course for free
I'm sure there's there's other courses
out there that are good as well but just
from my experience that's where I took a
course on it but that's great advice
Thanks thanks for writing that Andre
okay Oscar gave an answer to the
question about this being a wordpress
custom theme basically it says he says
correctly I created a static site first
and then converted it to react and then
through the content on WordPress so yeah
you can check check into it more in the
the repos to get github repos that are
linked in the description and then also
some of the previous shows I explained
more about how I set up WordPress and
everything
Rohan says I haven't touched react and a
really basic knowledge of other
frameworks but I'd still recommend
getting to know vanilla Jas vanilla
JavaScript in and out yeah that's
definitely that's great advice actually
the the person that I interviewed for
the dev job the web dev job yesterday
gave a similar response because I asked
I asked the question about what do you
think about different frameworks like
what are your thoughts on like reacts
versus angular or what do you think
about jQuery and he said and this was
the response I was actually hoping that
he would say he said you know it doesn't
really matter about the frameworks
because there could be another big
framework a couple of years from now
what really is important is knowing
vanilla JavaScript and then you can
learn any of the frameworks that come
out and I thought that was a great a
great answer and this is you know
basically what would rhoann saying as
well you know don't at first if you're
starting out don't worry so much about
learning one framework learn javascript
well and you'll be able to pick up any
framework you very quickly Sergio says
this J's learning resource really got me
hooked at some es6 Coty's org yeah I've
actually checked that site out before it
is really cool so es6 Coty's K 80s org
has some cool resources for obviously
learning es6
Andre says one that is cool more towards
gaming is the bug smashers series from
the star citizen Channel okay cool
I haven't I haven't checked that out
before but that sounds cool I'll have to
check that Oh Philip said my comment was
a joke shouldn't use an emoji alright
sorry Philip I do that sometimes people
joke and I'm like so focused on trying
to answer the questions and the best way
I can that I just totally don't even get
that some things are jokes so sorry that
went right over I had Andre says thank
you thank you Jesse your videos are
really inspiring rohan says so when do I
start
yeah honestly if anybody is interested
let me know
like just direct message me on Twitter I
can give you all the info you need to
apply for the job here I'm not gonna be
I'm not the one in charge of hiring I'm
just on the hiring committee so it my
opinion will count for a little bit
but I'd be glad to have you you're
working here with me it would
technically be working in another
department but we would probably
collaborate quite frequently but Rowan's
has been honestly apart from reacting a
couple of others most frameworks are
really easy and just comes naturally
just in an hour or two of working with
them that's that's true some of them
like oh when I first tried to learn
annular like way back when it was
angular one I had a lot of trouble with
that I think a lot of the trouble was
though that I wasn't experienced with
vanilla JavaScript first it wasn't
necessarily anything wrong with angular
it was just my knowledge I managed to
pick up react a lot faster and I'm still
learning a lot about react but if you
want to throw in jQuery into the
JavaScript framework
category you can pick up jQuery and like
I don't know a couple of hours and start
doing things and it's pretty easy let's
see
okay so Philip said that he may have
found one a wordpress API multiple
taxonomy query right so it's like why -
designs comm slash blog slash here let
me just let me just put it on the screen
so I don't have to read you this URL
which I'm sure is annoying to you so
it's basically I haven't gone there yet
so I'm not saying that this is good or
bad or anything this is just just
letting you know in case you're watching
later on and can't see the live chat so
anyway thanks so I will check that out
well probably not not because I'll have
to leave immediately so I can get home
in enough time for my wife to get a
haircut but I'll check that out probably
tomorrow all right so I'm gonna have to
end this which is cool there's not
really any other questions in the live
chat I've gotten to the bottom so I
really appreciate everyone joining in
and in watching and especially for those
who are contributing in the live chat
really helpful today and help me help me
find out some really obvious errors that
I should have seen but didn't so I
really appreciate everything I'll be
back tomorrow like I said earlier
probably a little bit later probably
2:30 p.m. I'll send out a tweet and let
everyone know exactly the time my
Twitter eye is in the description for
this video but it's Jesse are Weigel is
my twitter handle it's Jes se are w/e I
GTL
and like I said the the links in the
description so thanks for watching have
a great day
and I'll be back tomorrow